- Where you at, though? Where you at?
- 34, 24, shabloimps.
- Blip.
- Blip blip.
- Oh man, check this
out dog, check this out.
- Wait wait, what? Ooh.
- Look at his fine piece of ass
all the way down the street here dog.
- That's what I'm talkin' about, though.
- Oh damn.
- Hey girl! Yeah, walk this
way with that fine ass!
Blip!
- Ooh, yeah girl, why
don't you come down here
and put that in my mouth
'cause Daddy want a snack!
- Blip-bap takin' a bap.
- Why you hurtin' me,
girl? You're hurtin' me.
- Brisket. Brisket-y.
- Unh, that's deliciousness.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep it coming, yeah.
And that is a professional
basketball mascot.
- That is a man in an
orange rhinoceros costume.
(feet shuffling)
(costume squeaking)
- Hell, I'd (bleep) that rhino.
(western folk intro music)
- What can I say about ancestry.com?
My adventure began when I received a leaf
pointing me in the direction
of my great-grandfather
who was a pilot with the
Flying Aces in World War I.
- On my mother's side, I found an aunt
who traced her lineage all the
way back to Thomas Jefferson.
- I was able to trace my
bloodline back to nobles
and even a king.
- I discovered I'm a direct
descendant of Eric the Red.
- After only a couple of
hours on ancestry.com,
I was able to trace my family line
all the way back to none other than
our third president, Thomas Jefferson.
- Marie Antoinette
- Thomas Jefferson.
- Aristotle.
- Alexander the Great.
- Thomas motherfuckin' Jefferson.
- [Spokesman] Join ancestry.com and begin
a one of a kind journey
into your unique past,
because you never know
where your story begins.
- Thomas Jefferson.
- [Barack] All right,
you're doing fine sweetie.
Now Malia, let's just
go easy on the gas here
and come to a complete stop.
- Hey!
- Okay, so in the future,
you want to try not to go
through stop signs, okay?
(siren wailing)
Okay, just remain calm now,
and what you're gonna wanna do is
pull up right here next to the curb.
So this is why we wanna stay in the lines
and we wanna follow rules.
Remember this.
- License and registration.
(cop gasping)
Holy! Mr. President!
- Yep yep, just teaching
Malia to drive here.
- Well, you guys ran a
stop sign back there,
but that's okay, you can go.
- Oh, no no no, Malia's gotta learn
what it's like to drive
in the real world here.
This is called consequences, Malia.
Now I want you to go ahead
and treat us like you would
if I weren't the President.
(body thudding)
Not exactly what I had in mind.
- Hey, all I know is it's
good having another brother
move into the neighborhood.
- Hey man, it's good to have you over.
And I think that you will dig this.
- All right.
Hey, nice guitar collection.
- Oh, thanks man.
Hey, you wanna hear something?
- Yeah, sure.
- All right.
All right, let's get this
doisle on the stoisle.
(simple country guitar music)
♪ Well I'm just a good old American boy ♪
♪ With a heart that's
red, white, and true ♪
♪ Dreaming of the girl with
the red hair and freckles ♪
♪ And her eyes like the skies of blue ♪
- Country music.
- Yeah, I grew up in Texas, you know, so.
- All right.
♪ Keep her safe from the homies
on the wrong side of town ♪
♪ Where they're smoking the
reefer and acting like clowns ♪
♪ Keep that pretty white dress
from getting dirty and brown ♪
♪ 'Cause that's the American way ♪
Wee-hoo!
(Keegan chuckling)
- Whoa, that's a pretty racist song.
(both chuckling)
- Racist? Against who?
- Black people.
- Black people?
But I'm Black.
(Keegan chuckling)
- Well, keeping the red
headed girl away from
the homies on the wrong side of town?
- [Keegan] Homies?
Come on brother, there's
all kinds of homies.
You know, white homies, Asian homies.
- Nah, homies are Black.
- No, I think you're
making 'em Black, man.
I mean, I think that's your stuff.
You hear the twang and then
you assume that it's racist.
But that's just what
country music is like.
Here look, you're gonna like this one.
You like this one.
- All right.
(simple country guitar music)
♪ Some folks wear their
hats way off to the side ♪
♪ With their pants down low
and a gun tucked inside ♪
♪ Take their beer by the 40
and their chicken deep fried ♪
♪ I think we all know
who we're talkin' about ♪
♪ The only dark guy like is
when I turn off the lights ♪
♪ The only hood I love
is pointy and white ♪
♪ Can't trust you if I can't
see your face at night ♪
♪ I think we're all know
who we're talkin' about ♪
- Wait, wait, hey! Stop that.
That's racist.
- What's what?
What is racist about it?
- "The only hood I love
is pointy and white"?
- Yeah, man.
- That's talking about the Klan man.
- The Ku Klux Klan?
Are you outside of your mind?
That's traditional country
music imagery, man,
like a a pickup truck or
sleeping under the stars
or your dog got killed or your
wife left you, same thing.
- I would've been fine
with any of those things.
- What is the difference
between those things
and what is in the song?
- They're not racial.
- Hey, you know what, can
I just say something man?
I'm just gonna be frank.
You're getting a little like Al Sharpton-
- Oh man.
- Like Farrakhan on me right now, man.
- Oh my God, are you serious?
- Yo, dude, dude, please.
Hey, gimme, you know, can I do one more?
Let me just do one more, dog.
I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist
and it's impossible for you
to misinterpret it as such.
- Okay, it seems like you're about to
sing the most racist song so far.
- I'm not.
♪ Hi-Diddle-I-Diddle-I-Diddle-Eee ♪
♪ Get me a rope and find me a tree ♪
- Okay, I'm out.
- Come on man, hey!
Shoot, I'm over here trying
to sing about a tire swing.
Write off an entire genre of music.
♪ The banjo's a-strummin' ♪
♪ And the drums are a-bangin' ♪
♪ Let's get the boys together ♪
♪ And have ourselves hangin' ♪
Oh damn, now I see it.
Now I see it.
(funereal organ music)
- [Joseph] Hello everyone.
I'm Joseph Carmichael.
Otis is,
was my father.
But we are not here
today to mourn his death,
but to celebrate his life.
We knew Otis as a teacher, a
community leader, a role model,
a husband and a father.
Now, I thought it would be nice to share
something about him
y'all may not have known.
When my father was younger,
he was an actor in Hollywood.
Going through my dad's things,
I found this reel of his work as an actor.
I haven't seen it yet,
but I thought it would be fun to watch
here with all of you today.
(crowd murmuring)
(church organ music fading)
(projector whirring)
(woman gasping)
- Where are my pies?
Ribbles, where are the pies
I put on my window sill?
(comical music)
- Why, I dunno Missus Carruthers.
(people gasping)
Why would anyone wanna steal one of your
delicious blueberry pies?
(old-timey jazz music)
- Hey, see to it you shine
those shoes up nice, boy.
- Yes sir.
You best be believin' I will.
I'll shine your shoes
blacker than my mama's booty.
(people gasping)
(Otis laughing)
(dramatic music)
(Otis growling)
(people gasping)
Ooga-booga!
Ooga-booga-shoo! Ooga-booga shoo!
- Oh hello no!
(Otis grunting)
(projector sputtering)
(reel thudding)
(lid thudding)
- In 1964, my father marched
with Martin Luther King Jr.
and Harry Belafonte, along with
other renowned civil rights-
(interlude music)
(bar patrons murmuring)
(faint jukebox rock music)
(both chuckling)
- Well, well.
- Fuckin' Mexicans.
- Oh man, do not get me
started on the Mexicans.
- Hey, I'll just say it.
They hold the goddamn economy together.
- You know what, man?
Damn straight.
If 12% of the Mexicans who live
in this country stop working
just 12%, the USA would shut down.
I don't even care who hears me.
They, they, they work their asses off,
and they got strong family values.
- Essential immigrants.
(bottles clinking)
- Hey, speaking of immigrants.
(Keegan grunting)
How about them Asians?
- Them fuckin', you know what, brother?
You wanna light that fuse?
Then you better stand back 'cause
I got something I wanna say
about those motherfuckers.
- I got three words for ya.
Estudious, hard-working, industrious.
- Damn straight.
Asians are the highest
income, best educated,
and the fastest growing
racial group in the US of A.
- Plus, got the highest
percentage of college graduates
in the country, good for them.
- And maybe this makes me sound racist,
but those motherfuckers?
They're gonna save the country.
- There it is, you you went and said it.
(bottles clinking)
- I just said it.
I just came right the
fuck out and said it.
- It was in everyone's mind-
- But I'm the one who said it.
- Hey, and you know what?
While we're at it, I'm
gonna break my spine
tip-tap dancin' wancin' prancin' around
the elephant in the room.
- Yep.
- Blacks.
- Fuckin' Blacks.
- Blacks!
- Fuckin' Blacks, you know
what you done done did?
You opened up the flood
gates now my friend.
Released the Kraken.
- Goddamn victims of
institutionalized racism.
- And despite all that,
they overcame the slavery
and the segregation
just to become CEOs and entrepreneurs.
- Hey, one of em's the goshdarn president.
- And I mean, that's
just true right there.
That's just historical fact,
man, can't even argue that.
(Jordan chuckling)
- Oh, how about the Indians?
- Fuckin' Native Americans.
- I don't know if I could
get in trouble these days
for saying something like this,
but they were here first.
- Uh, it may be unpopular, but it's true.
- We came to this country
and we steamrolled on
in and we genocide them.
I mean, hell, we owe 'em somethin'.
- There ya go.
(bottles clinking)
- I gotta tell you, man,
that's not bad for a non-alcoholic beer.
- Not bad at all.
All right, I gotta go
home, take care of my kids.
- How many of 'em you got now?
- Just adopted the 11th.
Can't help myself.
- Man, that's always what happens when
you volunteer for the
earthquake relief in Haiti.
- Yep yep yep.
- What ya gon' do?
- Whatcha gon' do?
You know, my wife makes
two thirds of what I make.
- What? Y'all got the same job, man.
That's just patently unfair.
- That's right, we're both librarians.
(Keegan belching)
You all right?
- I'm okay.
(funky percussive theme music)